Monkey D. Luffy is know for humiliating opponents
throughout One Piece.
Unless.. he's fighting one of these eleven
characters..
For someone who is a Shounen protagonist and
should have the thickest plot armour in history,
Luffy has actually been defeated at least
11 times.
One of them is a major surprise, one is almost
as controversial as the zoro vs sanji debate
and the remaining ones all follow the same
4 simple step formula, that make one piece
so great.
Like the time Luffy got defeated and almost
captured by his Arch Nemesis Smoker.
Before even properly starting his adventure,
Luffy traveled to an island called Logue Town,
where Gol D. Roger, the first pirate king,
was both born and ultimately executed.
Here, Luffy runs into the marine captain Smoker,
who recognizes him form his first bounty poster
he just received after beating Arlong.
Smoker is the first character introduced with
the powers of a Logia Devil fruit power, that
turns his body into smoke, making him completely
immune to any physical attacks.
As a result, Luffy has no chance at all against
the Marine and is defeated in an instant.
He is only spared because his father Dragon
steps in to stop Smoker.
As a result, Luffy is able to proceed with
his crew towards the grand line.
The pattern Eiichiro Oda, the author of One
PIece, uses here, are the same 4 steps that
he uses with every single opponent, that is
able to beat Luffy.
He first introduces the villain in an impressive
way, showing how powerful they are and have
them defeat Luffy, in this case Luffy not
landing a single hit on Smoker.
In the second step, Luffy barely manages to
escape, like Dragon stepping in to safe his
son.
In the third step, this gives Luffy the need
to grow and be creative, either as a person
or in terms of power to overcome this newfound
obstacle.
Here, Luffy learns that he can’t beat every
enemy he faces and that sometimes you have
to simply run away to come back stronger.
Which leads to step 4, Luffy succeeding in
his mission, like in this case, making it
to the entrance of the grand line.
You can see the exact same formula with Luffy’s
third major defeat in the story as well, when
he encounters another marine, this time one
of the 3 most powerful marines, the admiral
Aokiji early on in the story, one of the most
powerful characters in the entire story, period.
Aokiji, just like Smoker is a Logia fruit
user, who’s entire body is made of Ice and
can’t take physical damage without an ability
called Haki, that Luffy only learns later
on in the story.
With Luffy having no way of dealing any damage
to his opponent once again, he is frozen solid
by Aokiji.
Step number 1.
However, as we learn a little bit later in
the story, Aokiji is more of an ally than
an enemy to the straw hat crew.
He just wanted to test Luffy’s resolve and
if he was actually worthy of watching over
Nico Robin, a girl that has been chased her
entire life and that Aokiji had saved as a
kid.
Thus, he doesn’t actually capture or kill
Luffy, but spares him.
Which is how Luffy, Step number 2, escapes.
Even though Aokiji tells him that he should
send Nico Robin away, because she will only
bring trouble to him, again this was a test,
Luffy has already accepted her as part of
his family, Step 3, and is able to proceed
towards Water 7 to get his ship fixed.
Step, number 4.
And speaking of water seven, Luffy has his
butt kicked by another official from the world
government, the organization that leads the
Marines and rules the world, who want to capture
Nico Robin for her knowledge about the lost
history, they are trying to keep hidden from
everyone.
The government agent Lucci has eaten the leopard
devil fruit, that gives him the ability of
the animal plus superhuman strength and endurance.
The leopards speed combined with the 6 special
techniques known by the the governments top
agents make him the first opponent in the
story, that Luffy could actually touch in
theory, but who is simply physically too fast
and strong.
As a result Luffy is utterly humiliated in
this fight.
The difference in power is so bad, that Lucci
has no interest in finishing Luffy off at
all and instead simply tosses him out of the
building before he leaves the island with
the captured Robin.
Therefore Luffy survives once again.
This time, in order to save his crew member,
he trains hard and develops 2 new techniques
for his devil fruit, that allow him to defeat
Lucci in one of the best fights of the series.
As a result he ultimately manages to liberate
Robin in my personal favorite moment of the
entire show.
Now you might or might not have realized,
that I actually skipped one of Luffy’s major
defeats: Against the Warloard Crocodile during
the Alabasta saga.
luffy didn’t just lose once against him,
but actually twice.
Just like Smoker and Aokiji, Crocodile is
a Logia devil fruit user who is made of sand.
Thus Luffy’s punches do nothing once again
and he is gruesomely impaled.
This time, he only survives thanks to Robin’s
help, who is still an enemy at this point.
I hope you see how nicely all of these defeats
are connected.
In this case, simply getting stronger won’t
be enough, so Luffy has to use his creativity
to overcome this enemy.
He has figured out that his fist covered in
blood can deal damage to Crocodile, since
sand’s weakness is moisture.
So for his rematch he brings a barrel of water
to the fight and manages to take Crocodile
out that way.
That allows him to save the kingdom of Alabasta
and free Nico Robin from her dark past as
well.
Dark, like the dwelling place of the 5th character
that managed to defeat Luffy.
This one might come as a bit of a surprise,
even if you have already watched up to this
point.
I definitely didn’t remember that this happened
at first.
On Thriller bark, Luffy faces Gekko Moria,
one of the seven warloards of the sea, that
has the unique ability to steal people’s
shadows and infuse dead objects with them.
Now this defeat was really sneaky, but as
Luffy and Co were infiltrating the spooky
castle, they got trapped in a room with countless
of Moria’s zombies, who had already managed
to take Zoro’s shadow.
And while Luffy was facing the Zombie who
now had Zoro’s powers and personality, he
was overwhelmed by tiny little spider mice
zombies who managed to seal him inside a coffin,
so that Moria could steal his Shadow too and
infuse it into the ancient giant oars.
To be fair, it was not exactly a 1v1 in this
case, but Moria’s entire character was centered
around letting others fight for him, plus
it was his devil fruit ability that took Luffy
out.
Luffy once again managed to escape however.
He infused himself with hundreds of shadows
and becomes nightmare Luffy, still one of
the coolest forms he has ever had in the story,
and manages to take back his shadow and defeat
Moria.
___
But while this defeat might have been the
most surprising Luffy has every experienced,
it is nothing against what happens next.
Travelling from Thriller Bark to Sabaody Archipelago,
Luffy and the crew experience their most crushing
defeat yet.
He attacks one of the world nobles, the rulers
of the world, who was trying to buy his mermaid
friend Jamee as a slave.
This is the highest crime anyone can commit,
and so the Goverment sends over another one
of the 3 Marine admirals.
This time it’s not Aokiji, but Kizaru, who
ate the light logia fruit, once again making
him an enemy Luffy can’t beat.
On top of that there is also Kuma and Sentomaru,
who decimate the entire crew.
Luffy doesn’t know yet, that similar to
Aokiji, Kuma actually does this to protect
Luffy and the others from being captured or
killed by Kizaru.
That way Luffy escapes by being teleported
to another island.
However in this case the growth from this
defeat doesn’t happen right away, making
this the curious exception in this list.
Instead, Luffy finds out that his brother
ace has been captured and is about to be executed
by the Marines.
So he goes on a mission to free him from the
hellish government prison impel down.
The main antagonist here is Maggelan, the
warden of the prison that has eaten the Poison
Poison fruit, that allows him to produce and
manipulate any poison imaginable.
He stands out from this list, as Magellan
not only defeated Luffy without any effort
at all, but also Blackbeard and his entire
crew, as they were infiltrating the prison.
Luffy only manages to survive his deadly poisoning
thanks to you being subscribed to the channel.
And also his newly made ally Ivankov, who’s
abilities safe Luffy’s life.
Luffy becomes immune to pretty much all poisons
hereafter and manages to make it out of the
prison and towards Marineford, the Marine’s
headquarters, where his brother had been taken.
However here at the marine headquarters, amidst
the biggest war in the history of one piece
so far, Luffy experiences the biggest defeat
in the entire story so far, which results
in the lowest point of his journey, to the
point where he almost gives up his will to
live all together.
Luffy isn’t defeated only once during this
war.
He is surrounded by characters way out of
his league, but through sheer will alone and
with the help of all the new allies he has
made, he manages to free his brother from
his shackles.
However, ultimately, Akainu,t he strongest
and crulest of the 3 admirals, is the one
defeating Luffy here, with his powerful magma
logia abilities.
The only reason his life is spared once again,
is because his brother and Jinbei sacrifice
themselves for him.
It is the first and only time so far in the
story, where Luffy doesn’t succeed in his
mission during an arc.
He wanted to save his brother and failed.
Which makes it the most impactful invent of
One PIece to this day.
However, Luffy did learn from his defeat.
It inspired him to become a better captain
who can properly take care of his crew and
taught him that you can’t always expect
things to just work out without any consequences.
And even better, to give Luffy a major payoff
and win after this gigantic loss, after a
2 year time skip full of trianing and new
abilities, Luffy is not only able to beat
the Pacifista that he had so much trouble
with on Sabaody, but he is now also able to
use Haki, the ability necessary to fight against
Logia type users like Smoker, crocodile or
any of the three admirals.
Which makes the next character that defeats
Luffy just the more surprising.
The crazy scientist Ceasar Clown, who rules
over the apocalyptic island Punk Hazard is
another Logia fruit user.
His body is made out of gas.
Luffy is able to survive Ceasar’s inital
poison gas attack, ethically quite questionable
by the way, thanks to his poison immunity
from the prison.
But then the scientist removes all the air
from the room, since oxygen is also a gas,
and thus makes Luffy pass out.
Very clever fighting.
Luffy once again manages to get away easily
with the help of his new ally, the warloard
trafalgar law.
Luffy learns from his earlier mistake and
takes out Ceasar in a quite satisfying manner.
Not as satisfying though as against this next
enemy that managed to defeat Luffy.
This is probably the most controversial and
maybe unique candidate on this list.
Charlotte Katakuri is the strongest pirate
in the crew of the emperor Big Mom, one of
the four strongest pirates who rule this part
of the world.
Katakuri has eaten the Mochi Mochi fruit,
Mochi being sticky japanese rice cake.
His fruit is pretty much the same as Luffy’s
rubber abilities, only that katakuri is better
at using it, he also has way better Haki abilities
and overall outclasses Luffy by miles.
He completely dominates their fight to such
an extend, that Luffy gets as frustrated as
we haven’t seen him for a long time in the
story.
He escapes in the middle of the battle to
think about his strategy and how he can catch
up to Katakuri.
Katakuri meanwhile starts to like Luffy and
pushes him to grow stronger until he is powerful
enough to defeat him.
There is a very strong argument here whether
or not Katakuri let Luffy beat him voluntarily
or not, but it is without question that Katakuri
beat Luffy during the first half of the fight
and that the battle followed the same 4 stages
as all the other defeats.
Luffy learns to use his devil fruit way more
creatively and even gains the ability to look
slightly into the future.
But this is nothing against what Luffy learned
from his battle with Kaido, one of the four
emperors, said to be the strongest creature
on the planet.
Luffy’s introduction to kaido is a defeat
with a single hit.
Luffy might never have been as out classed
as in this fight.
He has to go on an entire training arc and
escape from prison in order to take on Kaido
again.
And is still beaten a second time.
This time Luffy is saved by his devil fruit
powers and his will to live.
He grows immensely as both a leader and a
fighter, to the point where he emerges as
one of the strongest people in the story.
So there really aren’t too many characters
left, who would have a chance of beating luffy.
This guys here however is a different story.
Blackbeard is the main antagonist of the story
and will be Luffy’s biggest obstacle in
becoming pirate king.
If you want to know just how powerful he is,
and why he is able to wield 2 devil fruits
at the same time you can watch this video
right here next.